The joe rogan experience. What I wanted
to talk to you guys about is, uh,
some of my favorite stuff
that you've done. Um,
and so my favorite stuff that
you've done is the undercover shit.
And one of the things that I've found
the most disturbing was when you posed as
a gay couple and you went to that place
where they were advocating transgender
children and transitioning children
as young as three years old,
three years old, but puberty
blockers they were talking about.
But I think it was really fucking
yet. Oh, no, no. You know what,
actually three years old was Owen
Benjamin gotten an argument on Twitter and
lost his manager because he was saying
that someone is fucking insane for giving
puberty blockers to a three year old kid
for giving hormone blockers to a baby,
which I am. Fuck yeah. That's not
even a strong enough word. I mean,
it's insanity. Fucking insanity. I mean,
you're, your body's not even developed.
You're not even close.
We're not talking about 18.
We're not even talking about 21,
which is arguable is still crazy.
Like you really should probably wait
until your fucking frontal cortex fully
developed.
You figure out who you are,
but the idea that you're
going to know at three,
who are you going to be when you're 30
well, they present the other side. Banana.
They act as though you're crazy.
No one said. They were like, well,
you know the things with the puberty when
we're that person looked like Smi with
looked like SMI from hook.
Well let's play with,
let's lay some of it because it's,
it's fucking nuts. When I watched it,
I was like, oh my God. Like
what are these people saying?
And the there've been taken down since
you asked me about that to really? Yeah,
we have to set the blur. The Guy, well,
I'm not afraid who checkerspot drugs.
Dr Rex, but who shows up in price
name? My name is regs, but diarrhea.
We have a business card. Real world.
We're in a goddamn simulation.
This was a town hall. We're in a
simulation. This can't be real guy.
His name is rex. But, and he got
to the dig for a living, you know,
and you do back to back. Yes.
Okay. Let's play some of this.
And if there's a w for most of the
people are listening rather than watching
Jerry, do you know what, let's set
this up and turn. So what was this?
Okay. Uh, it was, well not gay, Jared
and I, so here's the one, let me,
can I preface this with some again,
we don't like,
we're not undercover journalists,
right? We do a late night show.
That's what we do. We
do, we did the modeling.
Would you joke sketches and we do
interviews and then every now and then we
stumbled across something. And
when you're doing, for example,
like Antifa and they hand you a
knife and they talk about shooting.
Been talking about that too.
But the point is,
and then when the media just lies
about it, like we feel compelled to,
this isn't our thing,
right?
It's just this is what this particular
one was kind of a throwaway.
It was a throat. We were joking.
It was a goof. It was costumes.
If you just walked in separate
queer, it was what? The health care,
transgender town hall. We was like,
oh my gosh. Trans Gender, town hall,
transgendered. Tom. Where was it at?
Vermont. Vermont. Burlington, Vermont.
That place is crazy.
I wasn't a plane with Bernie Sanders
on the way there to wow. It was,
it was Kimmy. I'm on money. I'm
going to give it to the blacks,
the blacks blocks. Right.
That's fine. All right.
He's about six now.
He has said that
it feels like a girl or first playing
with dolls and of course we don't want to
discourage it. Um, we spoke
with our primary care physician.
He said, wait until the,
the boys fully developed.
Develop is a little thick. That's
me. I would say a little bit
from the research I've
done the kid 18th too late.
It was just like, okay, get rid
of the poke. Puberty blockers.
They just go through late puberty.
Everything still lined up.
There's no indication that there's
any dance. That's not true.
Puberty blockers are not reversible.
That's the entire point.
That's not the point. Top of it. And, uh,
someone at the pre adolescent age going
into those adulent it's going to change
the way your body,
no question at all. I mean there's no
way giving a kid a puberty blocker,
letting them go through life with a
puberty blocker and then at 17 or whatever
the fuck it is decided
to take that shit off.
You're going to be the exact same human
being you would have been without.
People were worried about
a little estrogen and milk
cartons and this guy saying,
hey, free plastic cause I don't want
it to ultra my hormones. By the way,
I'm going to chop off my balls and do
puberty blockers at eight. But this is,
I mean you can't,
you can't let a kid make those decisions.
You can't make those decisions for a kid.
They're too young.
He just remember he had a
wiener five minutes ago. Yeah.
Was I thinking about these
things? No, no. He's just fine.
His book or off on the couch three
minutes ago and now you're letting them
decide is hormonal profile the idea that
a child who's six years old or whatever
would know the consequences,
but them saying that 18 is too late and
that it's not that they would disagree
with your primary care physician,
that it's too young based on
the research that I've done.
What fucking research have you done?
What you,
you can clearly point that it's a good
idea to transition a six year old.
Well here that's a problem.
Here's another problem.
We don't know if youtube is going to
ban this video because of what you just
said. [inaudible] t you this video is
going to get marked for demonetization.
Well, yeah, the,
the Jordan Peterson one just got
flagged and we talked about this book.
We talked about uh, the 12 rules
for life. We talked about, uh,
guidelines for living a hell just reading
it. That's great book. Let's keep going
to understand themselves and the task
or reach a particular day length and the
diameter and the penis is developing
up. Then there'll be enough if, if,
if you're going to check, if you're
going to transition to it away material.
Oh cause that's a problem. I be like,
you know, jazz material, creative vagina.
If the testicles and the peanuts are
developed enough, did you know this?
Did you know that unless
your penis gets big enough,
you can't get a fake vagina because
there's not enough tissue to in.
So he's like, this is him. He's like, no.
If you decide to transition the other way,
meaning if you decide to not transition,
eat.
Remember how everyone made fun of
this? Uh, the beauty pageant girl,
when she was asked about gay
marriage, she's like, and then,
and gay marriage or opposite marriage
and everyone laughed and it was silly.
You know what I mean? She was
conservative. It was silly.
But he's doing that right here.
Like should you choose to transition
or transition the other way?
You mean should you choose
to not cut off your penis?
That's transitioned the other
way. Now, not only that,
there's a lot of people in
the transgender community.
I think it's offensive to assume
that you have to get an operation,
get your penis removed,
nor to be transgender.
And what some of those guys making this
big assumption that this is what you
have to do in order to transition.
I know a lot of people
that are transgender that
do not have the operation.
I don't know a lot of people.
I just say I'm in a community focus
groups with transgender people.
By the way, let me say I'm 100% in favor
of grown adults deciding to transition.
I don't know. I think you should have be
able to tattoo your face. Get nose rings.
I don't give a fuck what you
do. I really don't. I mean,
you're also asking the government to pay
for your face tattooed. Yes, that's true.
Well, and there was another thing here.
I'll, I'll send this to you, Jamie.
Um,
that was some research today
that someone put out here.
I'll play this and I'll, I'll forward
this to Jamie. I'll Texas to keep playing.
That's it. That's it. That's
that clip. I Dunno. But yeah,
I mean that was the thing is, that's a
good example. It's a public town hall,
which we attend and it gets removed from
youtube because someone who handed us
his business card, rex, but
business card Arius, by the way,
like we didn't eat the rest of us.
We weren't nearly as mad about this
as we were just, just, just in,
in doubled over in laughter
at the guy's name is rex.
I had trouble getting less secure in
the URL, writes do his own nation.
There was a gun politely to her website
and you run a have to go to the URL.
Yeah, I just sent this to you, Jamie.
If you follow the tweet. Um, it is, uh,
by Dr Deborah. So, and uh, it is, um,
uh, article, uh, from the National
Institute of Health Study,
Dr Zero van meter, a pediatric. Oh, okay.
Oh, well, she's anti all this.
They don't give any leeway to Asians.
I,
it's the minority group that they
actually get more crap. It's like, well,
you're up. You have to be better than
everyone to get into a good college,
to just so many. Really good
ones. Okay. A doctor, Q van meter,
a pediatric endocrinologist with
extensive experience in gender dysphoria,
which by the way is hate speech says
there is 0.0 evidence that the concepts of
gender fluidity and gender identity
have any scientific basis. Yeah. So um,
this is why she includes 0.0
that's the second zero there.
She's money thinking about cash.
Does it mean anything?
She's thinking about cash money.
Well,
I guess you could have 0.01% you could
have one 100 she wanted to make sure
there's no doubt. Yeah, she
started in those extra characters.
You've just got your house Bro.
She's very,
the extra two 40 characters
you say like hate speech,
gender dysphoria is still in the DSM
five the actual like the psychiatric
journal and the use of reference book,
but they literally call it
hate speech now. Yeah, I know,
but it's the actual medical condition.
What's crazy that undercover,
God bless my wife,
she went with us because we need other
people to have hidden cameras and so she
posed as a lesbian movie kind of lesbian.
You're like, really? You exist and like,
Eh, she's taking even how the fool
they were, they couldn't say anything.
Well she remember said like
I feel I identify as someone
with bigger breasts and
she was asking how to get
this covered under Medicare,
medicaid cause they were talking about
getting all these operations and in Mr
Rec, God bless him Dr. Brooks, but I
think we should mention that, you know,
talk about that.
Gender dysphoria.
So for her they use gender dysphoria
to try and file it medically to get new
tickets on the taxpayer dime.
But it's considered hate speech to say
it to the train and the transgenders in
the room.
It's just crazy.
Like you can't make sense of it and
I don't need to make sense of it.
I just need to not be banned for dot.
Want to be the woman she was meant to be.
Right. Well I mean anything
that you can mock is bullshit.
I mean if you can mock it that openly,
if that's that obvious,
like getting the point of getting bigger
tits because you identify as someone
with bigger tits. I mean that's
bullshit. That's why it's so funny.
I've don't think I've ever been more in
love with my wife then when she did that,
I wouldn't expect that
she's looking at me.
She kind of not identified as
someone who has bigger breasts. Well,
did you see that guy that got busted,
uh,
molesting children and said he
identifies it being a six year old boy,
that was a really recent case.
I mean,
people are trying this out when
they get caught doing things,
and I'm not saying that there's not people
out there that identify with being a
man when they're actually a woman or
vice versa. That's not what I'm saying,
but what I'm saying is there's all a lot
of fucking crazy people out there a lot.
And to deny that and just because it's
dealing with gender, you're, you're in.
We're in Narnia now. We're in Lala land.
You're, you're not being real. No. Well,
let me, let me ask you this, because like
you said, you're, you're not right wing.
I'm pretty open about the
fact that I'm right wing.
I remember watching your show a while
back and you had a little little guy,
little guy, Jamie Kelsey,
a buck, buck angel. Yeah.
Little guy that used to be
a gal. Yes. Yeah, exactly.
And then I don't know what I said,
but at the same kind of
conversation we have here,
like I don't just go out and look
at the school, you you're training.
I said why don't I just
don't buy it. And he, he,
he wanted to get into a fight with me.
You wanted to have a fight.
Let's fight him out of this. This was
years ago when you had a fresh shot,
a test jacked. But you know it's
huge at one time. Oh was he?
Oh yeah.
It got up to like one 85 like super jacked
cause just banging test in there and
fucking lifting.
But he was saying that his joints hurt
really bad when he was doing that.
It's almost like, it's
unnatural, so crazy.
But back then when you get them on jacked
jacked and I had a role with that guy,
I'd be like fuck it. Go. No, come on.
And you wouldn't have problem with that.
That'd be kind of, yes. Yes,
exactly what the point is back then.
Let me ask you this. Did you
realize it was gonna get us insane?
Like where did you just
think of the tunnel? This is
an interesting guest. Well,
he's a nice guy and you know, I, I'm
more than willing to call him a man.
And that was one of the things
that I said. I said, look
man, you're a person, um,
who, whatever your name is with its
buck or Fred or Wilma, I don't care.
I just,
whatever you want to be called,
I'll call you whatever noise that you
connect with you as a being. Yeah,
I'm fine with that.
And if you can explain to me where
you feel happier being a man,
I'm 100% in support of you doing that.
What drives me crazy is people
making decisions for six year olds,
people pushing six year
olds in certain directions.
And I know that this does happen.
I know and I,
I can't get too personal about this,
but I have a friend who has an ex wife
that turned his child into a girl.
Yeah. And, and like tried this and was,
was pushing this and kids
are very fucking pliable man.
This is not,
I mean maybe some boys would have rejected
it and maybe he was leaning that way
anyway, but she was excited
about it. And this is,
this is something that a lot
of people are excited. I mean,
we're talking about a 14 year old,
I mean,
I just don't think you
know who the fuck you are.
You know what is that girl's
name? Ruby rose. Is that her name?
The attractive a lesbian with the tattoos.
She said that when she was young she
wanted to transition and she's very happy
that she didn't, she wanted to become a
man and she's very happy that she didn't.
And she's a lesbian and she's happy
and she's open and super successful.
But she's advocating the sorta
the same thing that I'm saying.
It's like let people become a God
damn adult and then make these in,
in alterable life.
Changing decisions.
This guy saying that hormone blockers
can be turned off and then you could go
through a normal puberty.
You're out of your fucking
mind. Right. I'm not a doctor,
but I have enough understanding of
biology to know that. That's crazy.
That's just not true. No,
it's absolutely not true.
And that's one of those things is,
listen,
anyone can get lost in the weeds
and make someone look stupid.
Something specific, you know,
whether it's, it's, I mean,
you were showing me that compound
both there. It's fascinating.
I don't know anything about it.
I'm going to be a moron. You know,
less than room temperature Iq.
Some doctor can come in
who's pro transgender and
explain something and make it
sound like we don't know
what we're talking about. So
when it comes to that, see,
I don't, I don't agree with
you there. Well, I don't
agree with you on their terms.
We wouldn't know. Right? Doesn't matter.
What terms are there that you don't know
about a child's biological development?
Well they,
what they point to the,
well actually there are these studies
that showed up the, you know, the, uh,
the brain alterations occur before,
across a hormone sex replacement therapy.
And it's actually, it's not true. So we
had a few transgender people on our show,
but the point is with these, whether it's
a conspiracy or, or that you'd say, okay,
I'm not a doctor,
but I can't just appeal to authority.
I can't just say this doctor says x.
So I do have to at this point accepting
that I'm not a doctor except the
preponderance of evidence from
the overall medical community.
And combine that with the
anecdotal and combined that with,
is there a motive here?
Is there an agenda here?
Like a lot of conspiracy theories and
just doesn't add up because who benefits
from telling you, you know, the
world is flat, who benefits from it?
Now I can understand how someone might
benefit from a conspiracy was like, oh,
they make a lot of money off of this.
Or was it Tim Kennedy as a hunting Hitler
thing? I'm not saying it, but it's like,
okay,
I understand.
After a war they thought maybe they had
Hitler and they needed the healing for
the country. Go, okay, I can understand
that. But with this, there's, there's,
it just doesn't add up to none
of the arguments they at ups for
millennial parents to whack off turning
the age of their children to social
experiments.
It's
okay.